tandis qu une cinémathèque municipal
fonctionne à lyon salle basse est la
cinémathèque française prend ses
quartiers dans la ville natale des
frères lumière il y a quelques jours
henri langlois le directeur de cette
mecque du septième art est venu donner
dans la coquette salle de la montée des
carmes le coup d'envoi d'une aventure
qui s'annonce fait qu'on rit langlois
c'est la réalisation d'un rêve de 20 ans
ah oui ça fait bien 20 ans nous avons
fait nos premières projections ici nous
avons toujours voulu avoir quelque chose
à lyon j'ai eu toujours des difficultés
des obstacles dans matériel de
psychologique d'or financiers depuis
maintenant ça y est c'est fait
finalement les obstacles ont été
surmontées andré jarlot zac de la salle
louis le premier obstacle ses terres où
trouver une salle pour jouer tous les
soirs à lyon c'est impossible
l'année dernière nous avons trouvé la
solution qui était de jouer dans
plusieurs salles puis certaines salles
nous ont manqués et cette année c'est
fini nous allons jouer non pas tous les
soirs mais au moins cinq soirs et
comment se fera la programmation à la
preuve programmation est structurel
c'est à dire qu'il ya un certain nombre
de manifestations sont prévues sont qui
auront lieu n'est ce pas nous imprimons
un programme d'ailleurs à ce sujet avec
des programmes catalogue des
renseignements et puis nous avons laissé
des trous de façon à pouvoir laisser
passer mais c'est raté aucune occasion
par exemple système vers une personne ne
savait qu'il serait en europe cette
semaine en france
c'est exactement cette semaine et bien
c'est un guerrier là nous en profitons
de la menons à lyon pouvez vous nous
rappeler combien vous savez le film
tombe bien nous avons actuellement
cinquante mille fine nous attendons il
ya un problème de place qui a retardé
l'arrivée de 25000 chine mais ceci n'est
rien parce que la grande chose de cette
année c'est que l'industrie m'ont
construit la grande industrie
internationale a décidé de transférer
ces absences de nous confier ses biens
pas seulement ceux qui sont en france de
ceux qui sont pas étrangers et parmi les
plus ardents défenseurs de ces films
bien figurent deux metteurs en scène qui
est à lyon en même temps encore il
angoisse celui de roberto rossellini et
de françois truffaut
deux bars oui oui parce que vous allez
voir ils sont des milliers roberto
rosselini il y à des metteurs en scène
qui se désintéressent complètement la
cinémathèque et d'autres qui se
passionnent pour elle dont vous pour
quelles raisons
sinon attaqué très utile puisque sert
pour former et et de le goût je joue dit
elle de nouvelles audiences
et puisqu'elle serrar proposer un tas
d'or alcool augmente de salses aussi
c'était marc accueillez ou pas comprise
etc
vous venez de le contracter un mariage
avec la télévision je pense que c'est
une date importante que cette prise du
pouvoir par les quatorze satellites vous
avez proposé récemment je sais pas si
c'est une date importante
je peux vous dire ce soir et étaient mes
propos je craque
c'est absurde que on maintienne de
télévision et le cinéma c'est pas les la
télévision est encore un moyen
formidable pour ce pour toucher un
public toujours plus vaste et jusque là
qu'il faudrait 6 s établissent une
association ou une collaboration entre
le cinéma la télévision
cette émission va devenir un film qui
sera commercialisée c'est là une formule
tout à fait original tout à fait neuve
c'est déjà un film il va être
commercialisé comme un crime c'est
l'émission qui est déjà un film oui mais
c'est une façon c'est une façon de
pouvoir faire du cinéma
sans se plier aux impératifs commerciaux
exactement la télévision la présente une
base et une fierté et qui permet
justement il faut évidemment avoir tout
il faut contenir les prix de production
avec ce talent mais si on travaille bien
en faisant un effort pour ne pas jeter
de l'argent par la fenêtre c'est plus
que suffisant pour faire un bon produit
asham alors la lutte entre la télévision
et le cinéma est terminée on va reparler
maintenant d'une d'une libération du
cinéma pour l'atv malheureusement elle
n'est pas terminée mais je souhaite que
fermin puisque un but absolument absurde
une cinémathèque est un endroit où on
aime le cinéma bien sûr mais aussi un
endroit où on discute beaucoup
françois truffaut est ce que votre votre
intérêt pour la cinémathèque vient d'une
nostalgie de votre ancien métier de
critique
non pas exactement mais vous savez avant
d'être critique j'étais cinéphiles et je
crois que finalement cinéphile je n'ai
pas cessé de l'être
je crois que ça fera cette année vingt
ans je vais la cinémathèque puisque il
ya une vingtaine d'années elle existe et
c'est une petite salade de messi d'un
pari de 60 places et je crois que je
n'ai guère cessé d'y aller depuis 20 ans
et je continue à aimer tellement le
cinéma qu'au moment de commencer un
nouveau film je suis quelquefois inquiet
à l'idée des films que je vais rater
puisque pendant le tournage je peux
quand même pas l'air si matech la
filiale de la cinémathèque à lyon va
proposer beaucoup de rencontres avec des
metteurs en scène important avec des
vedettes est ce que vous croyez
la vertu du contact d'un hectare
ancienne avec le public
peut-être mais enfin pour moi
l'essentiel sont vraiment les films vous
savez et de connaître les anciens films
ça permet d'avoir un jugement au moins 2
de porter un jugement personnel sur les
films d'aujourd'hui parce que ce qui est
frappant là que si les maquettes à une
distraction populaire c'est que beaucoup
de gens ne savent pas quoi penser d'un
film quand ils sortent et je crois que
c'est parce qu'ils manquent de repères
parce qu'ils n'ont pas vu les films qui
jalonnent l'histoire du cinéma alors de
bien connaître l'ancien cinéma permet
d'avoir deux des idées nettes et
précises quand on est de ne pas se
laisser influencer par le snobisme mais
par quoi que ce soit